tu sei brutto pensione picca necessità
risente nell'italia o italia e orsi
nuova challenge la assumptions challenge
in pratica nazionale che è stata
inventata sempre su youtube us però ho
visto quasi in italia 61 youtube che
l'ha fatta che sia miss crimi crimi che
la fate quindi mi ha intrigato questa
rara l'engine fatica come funziona su
instagram vi ho fatto un sondaggio
cioè domande in cui mi chiedevo scrivi
una cosa su di me che pensi che sia vera
quindi una funzione che gli altri
pensano su di te ma potrebbe essere vero
potrebbe non esserlo quindi ora vado a
leggere le risposte che sono piaciute di
più che mi hanno divertito di più
insomma non tanto per vedere come sono
un po offensive ma vediamo e confermerò
se sono vere o non sono veri
innanzitutto vi ringrazio perché mi
avete scritto tantissimi complimenti
siete stati super carini desiderosi
dolcissima dei gentilissimo dei troppo
bravo ma non era lo scopo della
challenge appunto di forlì dei
complimenti lo scopo era di dire
qualcosa che pensate che possa essere
vero ma non sapete se lo è quindi siete
pronte io posso confermare qui
attenzione
vediamo subito allora numero uno azzurra
ea chi mi dice nel video ci avete il
pigiama quale fosse il video di quel
giorno però se non sei diretto in genere
io il partito bravi vento ma sotto i
pantaloni del pigiama nel centro e
costano troppo perché io stesso con le
gambe incrociate non ce la faccio più a
stare con le gambe seduta normale
insomma e quindi mi danno fastidio
perché mi tirano e con i pantaloni
fertilizza mostro comodissimo quindi ha
indovinato questa stazione era giusto
non solo per il video di oggi di quel
giorno lì ma per genova tutti i video
sei bellissimo e mangimi meno di vitale
allora è bene non è vero non è vero
perché alle volte oggi più di allora è
verissimo piumaggio meno di vitale per
capitale malè già tantissimo e lo devo
fermare io perché sennò non si ferma il
migliore valli stomaco periodo cosa
spirito ed è rimbalzata soldo dice sì
ricca bravissimo perché non so da dove è
stato che noi per non fare che sono
ricca perché non ho neanche cioè nono
cosefir malate non ho una macchina gli
amici niente pezzi che fosse per erika
dunque non sono veri geek che sarebbe
bello ma ricordati che la felicità
una felicità non vanno assunti saputo i
soldi non fanno la felicità
assolutamente penso anche se fossi ricca
alla fine le cose che mi rendono felici
sarebbero le stesse
quindi no ma non sono rica pro fatemi
sapere perchè pensate che sia ricca so
che non ho tanti ricordi e simpatia
ludovica dice dall'alto profilo sembri
un denti versata e come l'avete scritto
in tantissimi mi avete scritto cambia la
foto profilo è brutta alto profilo poi
ce n'era un altro che dopo vi farò
leggere non mi ricorda che punto sta
comunque vi racconto la storia della mia
foto puro san nilo e anche il perché non
la cambia la foto non l'avevo me l'ha
fatta vitale ma non l'avevo fatta per
youtube l'ho fatta prima di aprire il
canale perché in pratica faceva un corso
di recitazione è un giorno c'era un
workshop con un casting director quindi
quelli che scelgono gli attori i costing
soli dei casting era venuto dall'america
e se aveva spiegato come presentarsi a
un casting
insomma tutti i consigli queste cose qua
e là ha detto che siccome quando fai un
casting prima mandi il curriculum con le
tue esperienze e poi nei casting per
attori e attrici metti anche delle tue
foto hanno detto che per le foto era
molto importante indossare dei colori
accesi o dei colori pastello comunque
dei colori che risultassero abbastanza
accesi e pastello quindi ho pensato che
colora mi piace di più tre colori
pastello fatto quella foto è in realtà
non è un camice un coprispalle ne
abbiano un cardigan un coprispalle se
lestissimo avevo detto questo
sicuramente andrà bene per i casting
call in realtà quella roma foto foto per
del canale youtube
quella che sembrava l'unica abbastanza
professionale però in effetti è un po
troppo professionale quasi per youtube
perché sembra appunto una foto per un
casting per insomma la mettere un
curriculum non mettere su youtube
e poi se vuoi un giorno li facciamo così
la giornata sì ma io allora il motivo
per cui non la cambio è perché voi
comunque mi riconoscete subito da quella
foto e anche per me lo stesso con i
canali youtube che seguo quando la foto
li riconosco subito che sono loro
se la cambiassero ci metterei un po di
tempo ad abituarvi è un anno sto però
forse un giorno la cambierà scrivetemi
non ci muoviamo anche la carta sono
effettivamente nella zona si quando sei
abituato a seguire certo quelli
youtubers e poi dopo cambiano cambiano
lo fondò cambiano il loro ti senti un po
spaesato non è più quale se quello che
sta riguardando privo cioè io comunque
sono cambiate un bel po da quella foto
quindi sicuramente un giorno la camera
non vi preoccupate allora nessi turisti
dice se in mano e bellizzi di stilisti
vissi ma allora c'è questa concezione
che la bella al sito che sono magra e
bella vi assicuro che no non lo so io
non mi vedo tanto bella ma soprattutto
quando mi sveglio al mattino
quindi voi non dovesse sempre credere a
tutto quello che vedete non c'è su
youtube alla fine non è che mi sono
quasi sempre uguale però su instagram
spesso se farlo deve proprio qui e si
bene quindi non pensate che le persone
sono sempre come le vedete su instagram
anzi quello è il loro aspetto migliore
in genere però non paragonatemi alle
persone come le vedete su instagram poi
per il fatto 6 mag la sim hanno
tantissimo se lo metti sta ingrassando
un po però sono sempre stata così di
costituzione e quindi non è che mi metto
a mangiare poco cosa no
quando mandò quanto mi pare se non mi
sembra però non mi do proprio limiti
cioè non interessa dire no non voglio
ingrassare o cose del genere
no è importante mangiare e mangiare bere
mangiare tanto e verdure esatto ad ora
le patate ne mangia puntali e che vuole
quanto tale va dal forte poi quelle
fritte realtà tema di tante due chili di
patate a settimana come di qual è la
vostra verdura preferita io direi le
patate e i broccoli dei funghi e le
melanzane zucchine mai già disse a 18
anni o poligoni e grazie non so come dai
dedotto questa cosa che ho 18 anni ma
non sono molto più grande una media che
è chiaro però cosa sempre credo di saper
osare lista nuits dice che tu sei
inglese
che strano spesso me lo scrivete c'è da
sempre da quando portò il canale mi
chiedete se sono straniera non per
l'italia
non so se sia perché vivendo all'estero
da tanti anni parlo in modo strano
l'italiano forse un accento un po
particolare oppure perché ogni tanto
diciamo qualche parola in inglese perché
non ci viene in italiano per parlando da
tanto tempo in inglese spesso diciamo le
cose in inglese quindi scrive che si nei
commenti perchè pensate che sono
straniero o pensavate che fosse
straniere con quella nostra inglese sono
italiano e sono sarda ornella cereseto
dice lavori alla apple
allora ornella devi essere una
grandissima investigatrice cercava so
come hai fatto a capire che io prima
lavoravo alla apple non so come come ha
fatto perché non è che su instagram
abbia messo cose comunque non ho scritto
niente del genere mi sa che non l'ho mai
detto nel video non mi ricordo comunque
si era il mio precedente lavoro
ecco perché adoro tutti i prodotti e
come le mani da dare questo mi ha fatto
troppo ridere parata per i capelli tra
belli e curati mia fottorino perché io
non penso di avere dei bellissimi
capelli non lo so vorrei che mi
piacciono
non lo so è che io vedo sempre appunto
su instagram persone con dei capelli
stupendi non si disse mi lunghissimi
perfetti dico di il confronto di capelli
orribile tutti i frizzi però grazie mi
fa piacere
pensi questo grazie rini style pensa che
sono sposata che io entravo perché prima
ora dice che penso che ho 18 anni e
l'altra penso che farò sono carta ma
quei fatti arrivi da me comunque non
siamo sposati assolutamente lezione
leonardo ma a mali scrive che è molta
pazienza con vitale che mangia troppo sì
non ha molta emozione
verissimo però veramente la perdo spesso
laboratorio dopo anni che dico perché
come dicevo prima orbitale non sa non si
controlla mangia fino a stare mai scusa
allora posso dire una cosa mi hanno
insegnato che se stai a tavola e cioè il
piatto non è che mangi un po 8 e lo
lasci deve finire quello che cena il
problema che tu le porzioni questo primo
la porzione poi proietti così alti
american a lasciare le cose con un
omaggio tutto l'altro problema che
vitale mangia in dieci secondi ha già
finito
veramente io che modo con calma piano
perché mi voglio godermi il cibo lui
dopo che ha finito mi fissa così avete
presente il cane sotto il tavolo che ti
fissano sfruttando che li dai a un
prezzo di zibo uguale quindi immaginate
come vada tranquillamente il romanzo mi
parlerà più bello maschi bene solo di
evitare che mangia ciardi dice che tu
sei brutta beh non hai tutti i torti
dipende dalle giornate
così tanto bella senato pd c'e 6 29 anni
e allora prima vola bridge creati ciao
26 29 11 anni di differenza
oddio no 29 anni non so perché bensì che
ho ventinove altri così tanti ma non
ricordo fu morali dice il fatto che
nonostante tu abbia 700 mila iscritti e
sono molti gli ascolti tutti comunque
grazie riccardo tra l'altro appunto
ricevuto un sacco di questi tipi di
messaggi che mi scriveva te cosa
supercar in e mi dispiace non riuscire a
salutarti tutti ma vi ringrazio tutti
comunque e mi fa un sacco piacere quello
che mi scrivi perché io ci tengo
veramente tantissimo voi lo so che
sembra una cosa banale da dire ma vi
leggiamo sempre vediamo sempre cosa vi
piace corsa non vi piace cosa vi fa
divertire ci riempie di gioia sapere che
vi faccia modaco ridere è la cosa che ci
piace di più alla fine vedere questi
commenti modo spietato nella forza umana
ma su questo meglio allora febbre
guardato volete un mezzo soprattutto
vitale di nota per contenta di
ascoltarvi perché voi siete veramente
super sensibili anche come noi quindi ci
siamo pure ritrovati alcuni uniti ora
maria francesca dice a me piace tanto la
tua parte che aiuti gli animali io sono
undici anni sono quante vegetariane
allora in tanti mi avete scritto che vi
piace di me il fatto che comunque mi
piacciono molto gli animali e io l'altro
dice una cosa normale nel senso che se è
normale che alle persone piacciono gli
animali che li proteggano comunque che
se un po animalisti penso che ognuno di
noi è un po animalista meno che non sei
uno che problema non ti piacciono gli
animali il che erano però insomma vedo
che anche voi piacciono tantissimo gli
animali anziché siete super appassionati
che ce le avete che li difendete che
siete super sensibili anche voi mi fa un
sacco piacere allora quali abbiamo due
fatta michel cela calefati che dicesse
basta e sofia zoppetti dice mi piace
molto il legame che hai con gli animali
e lo rispetto molto alla rendendo tutto
gratis sofia grassi mille e michelle che
disse sei bassa allora non sono cosa lo
hai dedotto se dalle foto di instagram
si capisse andrete utilizzo che non
sempre più alta si è davvero tra
svizzera balzaretti ma così siamo
rimasti scioccati perché voi siete
altissime che tutti i giganteschi c'è
bambini di 10 anni 9 anni giganti alti o
mio dio ma antico marzia dice sembri la
dottoressa di malattie imbarazzanti
ora andiamo a cercarla ma penso che si è
sempre il problema della foto profilo e
camicie ce le teniamo a capire come
questa questa dottoressa si sa il
cardigan celeste oggi un po più è un po
più grande comunque però vediamo se c'è
un'altra foto che si vede meglio ma è
questa
non lo so allora se questo ok va bene
grazie molto carina quindi va bene sono
contenta che dici che adesso miglio ma
forse dice che adesso miglio proprio per
forse la postura il canale celerità lady
ziccardi sui capelli nella tua foto sono
neri o castagna allora faccio di avevo
ancora castani non li avevano tinti
messa quindi cassano rami chi scrive
alice mi annoiata la tua immagine
profilo però ti adora ricevuto un sacco
di questi commenti mobili già spiegato
il card dice che il pappagallo questo
nel burro e finto ma di barbetti adesso
si arrabbia non si ovviamente finto ma
mi piace pensare che sia per rossi
piacerebbe tanto avere un po gallo ma
vabbè per ora ci accontentiamo di questo
allora loro longo scrive nella foto
profilo di instagram sembra che tu abbia
una camicia quelle da ospedale
nuovamente quindi il camice dal
professore mai non sia stata prestata
ormai riconosciuta come dottoressa un
dentista maria grazia cottone di sedi ma
listas il vegetariano vorresti prendere
un pop a gandino e 6 dolcissimo e
attacca dunque per te e anche del
pappagallino sapeva che ospita brava
maria grazia se molto sveglia allora
ferrari tudenti dice che sei più alta di
165 secondo me everhart sa benissimo con
la mia altezza per come ho fatto a
capire che sono 165 perché di tu sei più
alta di 160 corso del libro chanel iman
gestite l'amiante stesso ha scritto
altre curiosità vero che ti costerà
tutta la nostra assumptions challenge
fateci sapere quale risposta via
mi ha divertito vedere le cose che
pensate che siano vere alcune sono
davvero bene perché siete super sveglio
intelligente e altri invece un po strane
comunque lasciato un bel laiche fatti si
sa perché altri challenge vorreste
vedere scrivetecelo nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo un pò a 4 castellini
ha subito cliccare per vedere io non so
chi altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao